[موسيقى]
هنا في دبي ، يمكنك
تجربة مجموعة متنوعة من المأكولات
في العالم للمطاعم البشرية ولكن
لا يوجد مطعم
للكلاب ، لذلك كنت أفكر فماذا عن
صنع واحد لهم ، لذلك هذا هو
عيد ميلادنا السعيد الذي صممته
تسوق بنفسي ، أختار كل لون على حدة ،
كل مقبض واحد ، وأختار كل شيء
لأنني أريد أن أريهم هذا
المكان المريح والجميل مثل
القصص الخيالية ، لذلك أريد أن أريهم أن هذا
هو
أحد الأماكن التي تحلم بها.
كلبك معًا هنا
واستمتع بوقتك واستمتع بكلابك التي
تقضي الوقت معًا
أعتقد أن هذا مكان خاص حقًا
ينتقل على طول الطريق من ألمانيا إلى دبي ،
كنت متوترة حقًا من حقيقة أن
كلبي يمكنه الحصول على جميع الامتيازات
التي تتمتع بها  بالفعل في ألمانيا مثل الغابات
التي تخرج في المتنزهات
لتلعب وأعتقد أن عيد الميلاد السعيد
هو أفضل سبب للقيام بذلك لأنه
يشبه الجو الجميل حقًا هنا
يمكنها اللعب حولها ويمكن أن تكون هي
لقد جئنا إلى هنا كثيرًا ونحب هذا
المفهوم وهو يشبه إفساد كلبها
والاسترخاء كإنسان ،
فأنا مهتم جدًا بطبيب الأطفال
لأن أحد كلبي عندما كان
صغيرًا كان ضعيفًا جدًا ، لذا كان هذا هو
الدافع لي  ادرس عن تغذية الحيوانات الأليفة
وأعرف مدى
أهميتها حقًا وأريد أن
أقدمها للآباء والأمهات الهزليين القدامى في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
مثل حلوى الحيوانات الأليفة يمكن أن تكون جميلة ويمكن أن
تكون صحية أيضًا ، ومن ثم لدينا
ثلاثة إلى أربعة بروتينات مختلفة لكل فرد.
يوم مثل لحم البقر ولحم الضأن
والدجاج
والبط والدجاج كما لدينا مثل مجموعة متنوعة من
استخدام
المكونات ، لذلك في حالة وجود
كلب يعاني من الحساسية ،
فيمكنه الذهاب إلى خيارات أخرى ومن ثم
أيضًا يمكن للكلاب الأخرى تجربة
المكونات المختلفة و  بعد ذلك يمكنهم
الحصول على بعض
الفوائد الصحية من هناك أيضًا
لدينا نوع من العديد من الأحداث أه
الجارية الآن
والأكثر شعبية هي حفلات أعياد الميلاد ،
لذا فإن أصحاب الكلاب والكلاب
يحتفلون معًا في
الميلاد.
هنا وهم يستمتعون حقًا
بكعكات عيد الميلاد الجميلة لدينا ، ثم
يبدو أنهم أحبوا حفلات أعياد الميلاد لدينا
هنا ،
لقد كانت ردود الفعل من العملاء
رائعة حقًا في المرة الأولى التي
يحبونها مرتبكين للغاية مثل هل يوجد
مطعم  بشر أو أنه
مطعم للكلاب ، وعندما أقول أوه ،
هذا مطعم للنكات
وأنهم مندهشون حقًا هل يوجد
حقًا هذا عدد قليل من أصحاب الأماكن
ويمكن أن تبقى الكلاب معًا في
الداخل لأن
دبي في أيامنا هذه حارة جدًا.  حتى الآن مثل
يوم عودة سعيد هو يوم سعيد للجميع